welcome back to CBS this morning and
welcome back to the Empire State
Building we're here on the newly
renovated 80th floor of the building and
these kiosks you're looking at are part
of the new experience for visitors
workers just put the finishing touches
on a massive 165 million dollar
renovation project and of course we got
an early look at it visitors will now go
from one bank of elevators to another
making their way up to that world-famous
observatory but before they get there
the 80th floor of this floor now gives
them something very cool to do on their
way to that view
welcome to the 80th floor after four
years and a hundred and sixty-five
million dollars the final piece of the
visitor experience is now complete we
were there as workers put the finishing
touches on the 80th floor and now on the
80th floor about discovering New York
City and the first thing you'll notice
something visitors simply can't get
enough of is the view previously
reserved for the observation decks above
the windows were covered over this is
the first time that our visitors get a
chance to see New York City on the 80th
floor and you can also explore other
tourist destinations from one of the
city's most famous that's no
kid-friendly I'll be a tourist in my own
city with touchscreen kiosks that help
visitors plan out a trip and download
the itinerary to their smartphones can
you build one of these in my living room
on the walls a mural a reproduction of
the cityscape drawn from memory by
artist Stephen Wiltshire after only a
chopper ride over Manhattan before we
only gave people two experiences the
line and the view
Tony Malkin the building CEO says now's
the time to move this Depression era
Marvel into the modern age the new
visitor center experience begins with an
interactive museum doubling as a history
lesson people used to race to get to the
top and now they actually want to soak
everything up and ends on the all-glass
100 and second-floor observatory
providing soaring views of New York City
this is a special spot you want people
to be able to experience the peace and
tranquility of being up here
and oh did we mention all of this opens
to the public today this morning let's
talk about price for a second to
experience all the innovations it'll
cost you at least $58 but if you're
satisfied to go only as high as the 86th
floor Observatory that ticket starts at
about thirty-eight dollars not a bad
deal there it's less than fifty cents a
floor but for now let's go back to Gail
and Anthony in studio 57 hope you're
stacking your quarters and getting ready
to come on down I think I really thank
you Tony I really do think it's money
well spent the day we are there it's so
nice to see the people that come from
all over the world all over the world
makes you very proud there's so many
languages it's a big stack of quarters
to get in there but as Tony said every
time you go yeah that view feels new it
really does it's so special